Speaker 1: So I've got a couple of pretty
horrible covid related stories, sadly, these
aren't fun stories, these aren't stories to
make fun of people.
These are really stories that are pitiable
stories, but also just another indictment
of the completely backward situation we have
in this country with who people or at least
who some people are willing to trust when
it comes to medical advice and the way propaganda
spreads and disinformation.
So let's start with the first one.
New Mexico health officials suspect two people
dead from ivermectin poisoning simul.
That's USA Today.
Similarly, Cobie reporting two New Mexicans
have died of ivermectin toxicity per state
health officials.
State health leaders say more people are taking
ivermectin to treat covid-19.
In some cases, it's been deadly.
The New Mexico Department of Health said two
people in New Mexico have died from ivermectin
toxicity.
Not much is known about either patient, but
one of them was battling a severe case of
covid-19.
It's a serious issue we need to watch, says
Dr. David Grace, acting secretary of the New
Mexico Department of Health.
New Mexico health leaders are sounding the
alarm on ivermectin.
Poison Control said there have been 20 exposures
to the drug this year alone already, double
the usual amount.
We've had cases of seizures, hallucinations,
coma.
You know, it can be very dangerous if you
take a high enough dose.
Officials say the majority of the exposures
were in the past few weeks, most to treat
or prevent covid health experts say the data
just isn't there to prove it works.
Our medical advisory team has looked at this
three times.
Still does not feel people should be taking
it.
And of course, the FDA has not yet approved
Ivermectin is almost exclusively used to treat
parasites in horses and cattle.
In rare instances, humans, same drug, different
formulation, different dose.
If you take too much, you go into a coma,
you may have seizures, you may have hallucinations.
It's a it's basically a neurological toxin.
Recent studies have shown it has some effect
on covid, but at a pretty significant cost.
When it was combined with standard therapy,
it had a lower death rate and progression
to severe disease.
But in that in vitro study, you needed clearly
toxic doses to achieve the effect on virus
replication.
I think that's an important detail to mention
here.
We had that call from a biomedical researcher
a couple of weeks ago who said, you know,
you have to understand that when a study says
that in vitro.
It kills covid particles, deactivates covid,
whatever term you want to apply, their in
vitro and in vivo are two different things,
but the relative dose of what you can do in
vitro could be completely toxic in humans.
And where I continue to go back is it's really
strange to me not to take something tested
given to billions and FDA approved the Fizer
vaccine and instead take ivermectin.
I just don't get it.
Like even if it's true that it might be slightly
effective for covid, if it's in addition to
all the standard stuff, but it can have real
side effects, which is dubious.
But let's imagine that's the case.
Why accept the cost when we have a vaccine
that is more effective?
And I don't know that we're necessarily going
to get an answer to that right now.
The USA Today article adding a few other details
that I wanted to mention.
The confirmation comes week, weeks after the
state suspected one person was fatally poisoned
by ivermectin.
The anti parasitic drug has not been approved
for treatment of viral illnesses such as covid-19,
but has attracted popular advocacy, particularly
among skeptics of the vaccines, treatments
and public health measures, such as masking
in public, including popular podcast or Joe
Rogan.
The FDA warned people against taking it, said
Grace.
The director of New Mexico's Department of
Health has previously expressed concern about
pseudoscientific messaging about the drug,
which is approved for human and Veghte use
against unrelated conditions, the state's
poison control center reported last week.
Calls related to ivermectin tripled compared
to twenty twenty different than than the previous
record of doubling that I mentioned.
Veteran.
This is also an important detail.
Veterinary veterinary formulations are not
approved for human use under any conditions
because the drug is often highly concentrated
for animals and the medications include ingredients
not approved for human use.
So that's ivermectin in New Mexico.
Next, we have a new one now.
Hydrogen peroxide vapor.
Yes.